والحقيقه ان اجواء رمضان مختلفه ربما هذا
العام في لندن بسبب لعده اسباب من هذه
الاسباب زينه رمضان كما ترون من خلف هناك
حوالي 30 الف من زينه رمضان من فوانيس
ونجوم والزنى الخاصه برمضان تم اضاءتها في
هذا الشارع هذا الشارع من يعني اهم
الشوارع الذي يربط منطقه
بساحه ليستر وهذه تعد احدى اكثر المناطق
ازدحاما في لندن طبعا هذه المناطق كانت
مخصصه في يعني دائما لاضاءه انوار الاعياد
مشاهد
نعم بالفعل يعني وهذه يعني كانت الانوار
تجذب
السياح لرؤيه الانوار في ديسمبر ولكن هذا
العام جذبت العديد من السياح الى هذا يعني
طبعا هناك من ياتي خصوصا لهذه الانوار
وهناك من ياتي طبعا لانه هناك
صدفه رمضان يعني احتفالات اعياد الفصح
المجيد ايضا في البلاد طبعا هي عطله رسميه
لمده اربعه ايام وبالتالي هناك توافق كبير
الى الى هذا الشارع طبعا هناك مليون و300
الف مسلم يعيشون في لندن احدى المقيمات
البريطانيات في لندن هي التي قامت بهذه
المبادره لاضاءه انوار انوار رمضان طبعا
جاء عمده لندن صديق خان للاشراق على اضاءه
هذه
وبالتالي يعني
الانوار
يعني تعتبر
ملفته للحديد لام العديد
من المارين